politicians actors writers musicians and
fans are paying tribute to author Toni
Morrison who died Monday her friend
Oprah Winfrey calls Morrison our
conscience our seer our truth teller she
was 88 and died after a brief illness
the Nobel laureates influence went far
beyond the world of books Michelle
Miller remembers the author who
transformed how we look at
african-american life I think I have a
distinctive voice Toni Morrison used
that voice to challenge beliefs on race
and gender definition she said belonged
to the definers not to define she wrote
that in her 1987 novel beloved about a
runaway slave who chose death over
bondage for her daughter the book which
later became a film starring Oprah
Winfrey and Danny Glover earned the
Pulitzer Prize kind of evil you got now
you ain't evil just said come on through
11 novel spanning more than four decades
Morrison delved into the struggles of
the oppressed
she received the Nobel Prize for
Literature in 1993 the first black woman
to accept the honor he was very much a
mentor to me
and a beacon Errol MacDonald says he
might not have become an executive
editor at Random House if she hadn't
gotten him his first job in publishing
what will you miss most I will miss her
guiding intelligence her whipped her
laughter and her abiding faith in human
beings
he says up until her death Toni Morrison
was working on a new book perhaps one
last peek into her lens on humanity for
CBS this morning Michelle Miller New
York what a phenomenal woman a real
truth-telling I was just saying during
the break that I went to a reading that
phylicia rashad and Andre Holland we're
at not too long ago and you just realize
how important those words were asking
you know who we are why we are and how
we could be better critical contribution
to American
there's no doubt